when we heard about richard we were
promised it was going to be like this
you know
really raunchy sexy and i was watching
it where
is the sex but my god once you pull the
rip cord it's it's non-stop
there's a bit i mean even you must have
been kind of you know at the table read
you must have been going
up i haven't spoken for pages
well i got my mouthful half the time
i was consistent on because i think
that's important to see on tv as well
because yeah
that is uncommon that you see that kind
of power dynamic in rauchi scenes
and that's part of the way that we did
want to modernize the show so the duke
does have his mouth full and he's proud
of it
um but yes there was there was a fair
bit um to be done
on the show because you're really going
for it but you're going for it in
kind of beautiful locations i mean
like and occasionally very uncomfortable
locations well those library steps
didn't look easy
um
didn't you have room monitors in the
stately homes well this is a problem
because the set as usual is more
valuable than any of the actors so if
you're in like you know a 200 year old
bed or a 400 year old four poster
um it has to have a reminder like you
know when people kind of bring very
expensive jewelry around they have to
have a
bodyguard there's a bodyguard for the
room and so all times you know you've
got this
minimal set everyone gets very quiet
very respectful and you kind of you
de-robe and you hit the bed
and then there's also just like fran in
the corner who's just standing there
just kind of deciding whether or not to
look she's like i have to look i'm not
allowed to look i have to look
could you could you please go easy on
the bed it's very very hard
it's not quite so enthusiastic oh do go
on
that's the inner monologue that i
imagined
i'll stop them in a minute
presumably you had to have the awkward
kind of family conversation before
yeah a little bit um i mean we've got a
family whatsapp group so there's a
couple of you know flash and red light
emojis and the odd peach emoji
um certain people have threatened to
rate my peach um
but we missed a couple of family members
and so people who enjoy the fact that
like a couple of cousins missed the memo
um and so they were watching the show
and i got a very stern message in my my
instagram dms oddly enough
just going i you there really needs to
be a cousin warming i had to make so
many tactical cups of tea
and i left the room and made my tactical
cup of tea and came back and you were
still going
so you had to start doing pots of tea
you know you had to kind of keep
building up the three-course meal a
tasting menu